Okay,
so we are about two weeks away from getting our cows at the dairy barn.
So I want to show you what the barn is looking like right now.
So up here is the overlook deck.
So you can come up here and see into the milk parlor.
You can see that here is where the cows eat,
and they'll always have free access to the pastures outside.
It's a pasture based dairy.
Those black mats that you're seeing are actually cow water beds.
So when the cows lay down,
it's very comfortable on the joints.
There's just tons of natural light in here,
which is what Daniel and I wanted.
And then this room I'm super excited about.
This is actually our milk bottling room.
So you'll see in here that we have the sinks in here.
And this is where we bottle all the fresh milk.
The tank is on the other side of the wall.
Fresh milk will come in here,
we'll bottle it,
and then we'll be able to sell it.
Fresh milk straight to you guys,
which we're super excited about.
And then out here,
Haley is finishing the Ballerina Farm sign.